Julia just mentioned that a few
of you had commented,
when we were
talking about the genetic code,
that some of you thought the
fact that it
was degenerate,
it had some redundancy in it,
like multiple
codons or threonine,
that that was kind of cool,
and some of you
thought it was sort of a waste
and would have maybe designed
the thing
differently.
That's, you know,
part of when you study biology
you don't
get to design it from first
principles.
You found out what happened
during evolution and what got
selected for.
And once it gets selected for
then that gets sort of fixed in
nature.
If there were four nucleotides
then you could have one,
two and
three-letter words.
And it's going to be a
three-letter word to have at
least 20 then you've got some
degeneracy or redundancy,
but that's
not necessarily a bad thing.
And, in fact,
if you go into the
evolution of the code more
deeply, people are beginning to
suspect it
evolved from a simpler one.
And there actually are some
relationships between some of
the codons that go back to the
similarities,
the chemical similarities
between the amino
acids.
And it also allows some things
for some cells,
for example,
if they want proteins to be
present at very low levels they
will use a
codon that has just a very low
level of the corresponding tRNA.
And if
they want to make a lot of the
protein they'll use a tRNA that
it
makes in abundance.
And so it's sort of another way
of
controlling levels of proteins.
There are a lot of different
subtleties in here.
And also in biology redundancy
is not
necessarily a bad thing.
It's just like on a space
flight, if something
goes wrong and if there's some
kind of redundant function then
you've
got some backups,
too.
OK.
Well, in any case,
today is a pretty
interesting first part of the
lecture.
I've heard a few people
express the view that why can't
I just teach what's in the
textbook
and get on with it?
And I think this part,
for those of
you who are following,
really trying to understand
what I'm trying to do
with this course,
I hope this will help you to
see this.
Because what
I've talked about,
this thing that Crick called
the "central dogma"
which was the direction of
information flow in biology
which
was from DNA to RNA to
proteins.
And I'll just remind you,
although
proteins do many things they
are, for example,
enzymes that are
biological catalysts.
And it was pretty
well-established,
even by the
time I was an undergrad that
this was the way information
flow went in
biology and this was how it
worked.
And there were various
statements in
the literature that what was
true for E.
coli was true
for an elephant.
And it is still true today in a
broad sense that,
as I've tried to emphasize
throughout the course,
when you get down to a cellular
molecule level there's an awful
lot
in common and things look much
more alike than different
compared to
what we see at a more
macroscopic scale.
However, that doesn't mean
that all the details are the
same.
And maybe you could begin to
get a
glimmering of that when I told
you that although the genetic
code is
virtually universal.
That almost every organism,
with
only a couple very tiny
exceptions, uses exactly the
same genetic code
to have nucleotides correspond
to three-letter words in the
nucleic
acid alphabet correspond to
particular amino acids in a
protein.
But the other languages that
are written in there such as the
sequence to start transcribing
a gene, making an RNA copy or
stop.
Those are different between
different organisms.
Yeah?
Glycolysis enzymes are
amazingly
similar.
They are very clearly,
they arose once,
and they have
stayed right through evolution.
You could, in principle,
sometimes in
evolution you get something
that creates a function and
something
that starts out,
and then like what they call
convergent evolution you
end up with two things that
came from a different
evolutionary origin
but have learned to do,
let's say, catalyze the same
biochemical
reaction or something.
Glycolysis came once.
But if you
were to look inside E.
coli or yeast,
let's say E.
coli and look at
how those enzymes are
regulated, the thing that says
this is the start of
a gene, start making the RNA,
it would look totally different
than if
you looked in a mouse because
the language,
the promoter does not have
the same sequence in an E.
coli and in a human or in a
mouse.
And I'll
tell you more about that today.
But there were --
I want to just now tell you
sort of three things that were
sort of
exceptions to this general way
of thinking.
Every one of them
generated a Nobel Prize.
And this is a fun lecture for
me to give
because the individuals
involved in all of these things
had a very, very
close association with MIT.
And when I told you when Crick
called
this a central dogma he meant a
hypothesis, or at least an idea
for
which there was not reasonable
evidence.
And he learned later it was
something a true believer cannot
doubt.
And once this gets established
it does get in the
textbook and it does get in
your thinking.
And so information goes
down this way.
But there were a few oddities.
I mean there were some
viruses that had RNA inside
them.
They didn't have DNA.
So how where
these handled?
Well, there turned out to be
two
classes of RNA virus.
One that was studied quite
heavily called,
it's a
plant virus called the tobacco
mosaic virus.
And it had a coat.
And then it had in it a piece
of RNA.
Now, you can see if that virus
were to inject RNA in the cell
it could encode proteins.
But that genetic material has
to be copied.
And the RNA was copied --
-- by an RNA dependent
RNA polymerase.
And so it's sort of just like
the
RNA polymerase before,
except instead of using DNA as
its template
it can use RNA.
So that sort of somehow would
be a little loop in
here about RNA being able to
copy itself that hadn't been
anticipated.
And although this is an
important virus in the plant
industry, for
plants and agriculture,
it's not so important for
humans.
But there's another class of
RNA viruses that are very
important.
And these are called
retroviruses.
And the reason these are so
important is that the HIV-1
virus that's associated with
AIDS is such
a retrovirus.
It's a virus that has a coat
and it has an RNA that's its
genetic material.
And the person who worked out
how
this goes was a person at MIT,
Dave Baltimore.
He was a colleague of
mine here for many years.
He was the person who founded
the White-
head Institute and got that up
and going.
And he then finally,
to move
up one more administrative
challenge, went to Caltech
to be president.
And that's where he is today.
And
David was working on this
problem trying to figure out how
these
retroviruses work.
And they're important.
Not only the HIV-1
virus, but there are certain
viruses that are associated with
cancer.
In
general, what they do is
they've picked up what's called
an oncogene
which is sort of often a
mutated version of one of your
normal genes.
And if that virus gets inside
one of
your cells and brings in this
mutated gene it's sort of kind
of
the same consequence as
mutating one of your own genes
along that
progression of cancer.
So it can kind of,
say, bring in a cell that
screws up the control on when
cells are supposed to replicate
and stop
dividing and so on.
So David started to work on
these, and what
he discovered was that these
viruses encoded,
they had information
encoding proteins.
And one of the proteins encoded
in
their RNA is an enzyme he
characterized which is given the
name "reverse transcriptase".
And what this can do is take an
RNA
template and make the
corresponding complimentary DNA
strand in this
way.
So that if we took the -- We'll
just take this RNA out of the
virus.
What this virus encodes then is
an enzyme that's able to take
this RNA and make the
corresponding DNA copy.
So there's the original
RNA that was in the virus.
There is the RNA that it
started out.
And so
what is happening,
if you will in that case,
is the information is
flowing in the other direction.
That was a marvelous discovery.
And it was discovered by
someone who
wasn't willing just to take
what was in the textbooks but
was trying to
figure out what could possibly
be going on here.
Now, the way these
viruses work then,
once they've done this it's not
so bad because they've
got their information now in
the form of DNA.
So this strand of DNA can be
made into a double-stranded DNA
by just
using the kinds of enzymes that
we've already talked about.
A DNA
dependent DNA polymerase will
be able to copy the other thing.
And
now you've got a DNA copy of
the information that used to be
in the
virus.
But what happens to that is
that you have a piece
of the host DNA.
And this viral DNA then inserts
into
it, so you end up with this
situation where you have DNA
from
the host, and this is the virus
DNA.
So this is the DNA that encodes
the information needed for the
virus.
And if this was our DNA then it
would be inserted that way.
And
there are just a handful of
health messages I've tried to
drive home in
this thing.
I mentioned smoking the other
day.
If you smoke --
If you stop smoking you
basically, well,
let me try another way.
The
risk of smoking is about equal
to the sum of everything else
you can
possibly do in your life that
will affect your chances of
getting
cancer, leaving aside what you
inherited from mom and dad.
The one
single thing to not do if you
want to avoid cancer,
or to help loved
ones who smoke avoid cancer,
is just don't smoke,
or if you
do smoke, stop.
You freeze the risk of whatever
increased risk you've got,
and then just live with that,
but it doesn't
keep getting worse with time.
The other one is practice safe
sex, and
this is why.
HIV-1 is a retrovirus.
If you get infected with it,
it
makes a DNA copy of the RNA,
it makes the other strand of
the DNA,
and it sticks itself in.
So what you've got is your DNA
here, your DNA there.
And HIV-1 is a permanent
traveling
companion for the rest of your
life.
There's no way of getting that
out
of there right now.
All the systems for dealing
with AIDS are just
managing the infection.
So when someone is HIV-1
positive, they've
got those viral genes now
permanently integrated
into their DNA.
So it's extremely important
that you
be aware of that,
or if you know people who don't
appreciate this
because they haven't got so
much of a biology background
that you help
them understand that.
OK.
So I just wanted to show you,
I found one
other picture last night.
And this is you see all these
old scientists,
right?
Of course, David didn't look
like this when he was doing his
work.
In fact, I think he's fairly
cleaned up here.
I found this one
in the Cold Spring Harbor
archives last night.
I've seen pictures of him
looking considerably more shaggy
and perhaps
disreputable and stuff.
But anyway, when David was
making all these
discoveries he was still quite
a young man.
I believe he got his
Nobel Prize when he was still
in his thirties.
And so many of these
discoveries are made by people
that are not all that much older
than
you.
But, again, it's trying to
understand why we know what we
know
and then trying to fit other
things into it.
Now, the next thing I want to
tell you about that has some of
this same
character, I've sort of told
you that you have a piece of
DNA.
Let's
say there's a gene here and
this is the coding region,
and then we make
a mRNA copy,
and then we use the genetic
code and we
make the protein.
And so if we sequence the DNA
and
find the beginning of this
protein we can read along using
that genetic
code and away it should go.
And that was beautifully worked
out,
understood, just like I sort of
finished up telling you the
other
day.
So Phil Sharp who got a Nobel
Prize for this work and is a
colleague in the Biology
Department.
He's in the Cancer Center just
across the street from the
building
I'm in.
That was the cancer center that
Salvador Luria,
who Jim
Watson trained with,
had founded.
And Phil was studying this
process.
It was before we could sequence
DNA.
It was in the mid '70s.
And he was
working with the tools we had
then trying to map the
relationship of an
RNA to a gene that was on a
virus.
It was a DNA virus,
not an RNA
virus, so don't get yourself
mixed up with that.
But what he had was
basically a fragment of DNA
that he knew encoded the gene.
So he knew
somewhere on this piece of DNA
there was a gene somewhere in
here, and he
had isolated the mRNA.
And one way you could map,
physically see the
relationship of an RNA and a
DNA would be to take,
let's just take
away one of these strands.
So we have the complimentary
strand
of the DNA to the RNA.
And if we mix them together and
let them
slowly cool down they will form
hydrogen bonds.
They'll form a
DNA-RNA hybrid just the same
way two strands of DNA come on.
And so if
the gene was a little shorter
than the piece of DNA then you
might have
expected to see something that
looked like this.
And the way you'd see this,
if you looked in an electron
microscope --
-- perhaps it would look sort
of
like this.
You cannot actually see the two
strands, but you'd see a
thick part.
That would be the RNA duplex.
So this would be just DNA.
And the thick part is RNA base
paired with a single strand of
DNA.
You got it?
That's what textbooks said you
should have seen.
And so
this is more.
This is data from Phil's paper
describing this.
And
let me focus on this one in
particular.
That's what
he actually saw.
You guys got any idea what's
going on?
Why don't you take a minute,
find somebody who's near you
and see if you can come up with
any ideas.
Here's the hybrid.
Forget about this little bit at
the 3 prime end.
That's not a worry.
Here is the thing.
And this, I think,
is a
piece of single stranded DNA
sticking out the end.
But it looks a bit more
complicated.
Any ideas?
Most people put this
data in their drawers.
Phil didn't.
Phil and his colleagues didn't.
What they realized was,
I'm going to try and redraw
this just very
slightly to help you see what's
going on.
What they were seeing was
something that looked rather
like what they
were expecting.
They were seeing a region of
hybrid DNA and they were
seeing a region of
single-stranded DNA like this,
but what it looked
like was there were little
loops of single-stranded DNA
sticking out.
And what Phil had discovered
was a phenomenon we now know
as RNA splicing.
And here's what goes on.
In bacteria,
with very few exceptions,
you can look at the DNA,
you can find the open reading
frame and you
can just read off the sequence
of the protein.
You find the ATG,
AUG,
methionine codon,
and then it keeps going no
stops, and finally you come
to a stop codon and you see
there is the protein.
So the coding
information is essentially
continuous in almost all
bacterial genes.
And there's a few,
some genes like
that in eukaryotes,
but many eukaryotic genes are
constructed,
it's almost as if you took the
gene you'd find in a bacterium
and then
you'd cut it in a bunch of
places and stuck extra DNA in
between all
of the pieces.
So you'd get something like
this where there's,
in the DNA there'd be coding
information.
And then non-coding information
and another block of coding
information.
And then a block of non-coding
and say another one of coding
information.
So this is a double-stranded
DNA.
And what
happens then when the cell
makes RNA is the whole thing
gets copied into
what's known now as a
pre-messenger RNA.
And so there's a bit of coding
stuff here, there's a bit of
coding stuff
here, and there's some more
coding stuff there.
But what the cell has
is sort of like your unedited
footage from your family summer
vacation when you were running
the video camera.
And maybe you don't want to
show everybody ever second of
video that
you took during the thing.
So what you do,
you get in there and you
edit it.
In the old days you used to
have to take the film and splice
it.
And now you can all do it with
iMovie or something like that.
But
what you do is take the pieces
of information you want,
and this is
what the cell is doing.
It takes this part of the RNA.
And this part of the RNA,
and joins it together,
and then this part.
And when it's done it has the
mRNA that now looks like the
kind of mRNA
that you would find in a
bacterium where you can find the
start codon.
And then you could read in
three-letter words all the way
through to the end of the
protein.
So, in essence,
what Phil found was
that in many organisms at least
there's another step in here
where
we get RNA splicing.
And only after that you get
down to proteins.
What was quite remarkable about
this result and why I'm kind of
hammering
on it a little bit is this is
the data that's out of Phil's
paper.
You can look it up on the
Internet.
Type in Phil Sharp 1977 and
you'll
find this original paper with
that figure in it.
The moment Phil
realized what it was and talked
about it at a meeting,
a whole lot
of people suddenly sort of
almost simultaneously discovered
RNA
splicing because they opened
their drawers and there were all
these
uninterpretable electron
micrographs they had.
And they were in very short
order able to save it in the
system.
The
same thing was going on,
but it was just confusing,
it didn't fit,
and
to some extent most people's
minds were set by this paradigm,
this
central dogma as something that
a true believer cannot doubt.
And you
had to have a flexible enough
mind to be able to see that.
And so this is an important
piece of biology that hadn't
been
anticipated.
And it can be quite remarkable.
I'm just going to give
you a couple of extreme
examples.
Well, not even extreme
But just show you how much
non-coding information there can
be.
Factor 8 is a protein that
plays a part in blood clotting.
And the
gene is 200 kilobase pairs.
And the pre-mRNA is just a
direct
copy, so it's 200 kilobases.
It's just a single strand so
it's not a
base pair.
And the actually spliced mRNA
when it's done is 10 kilobases.
So that means that only 5% of
the gene is coding information
and 95%
of that information gets thrown
away when the RNA gets spliced.
And even a more extreme example
is a protein called dystrophin.
This is
what's affected in a human
genetic disease known as
Duchenne
Muscular Dystrophy.
In this case,
the gene is two mega- base
pairs.
So of course then the
pre-mRNA is also two megabases
but the pre-RNA is 16 kilobases.
So in
this case less than 1% of the
gene has coding information
for making a protein.
There are a lot of interesting
reasons as to why it would be
like this.
One this, things can evolve
more rapidly sometimes because
you have parts of proteins that
are sort
of like modules and evolution
can probably connect them.
In fact, it also provides ways
of regulating because we now
know there
are alternative ways of
splicing RNA.
So you can take one RNA and
then splice it in different
ways in different cells and end
up
generating different proteins
that were all encoded by one
particular
gene.
And so it gives cells different
kinds of regulatory
strategies they can use.
Now, the third sort of thing
that
came out that falls in this
same kind of thing of people
having their
minds open and not fixed by the
current understanding or bounded
by
the current understanding is
the discovery that RNA can act
as an
enzyme.
And I've already talked to you
about that and I've told it was
ribozyme, but it was discovered
by Tom Cech.
Tom is currently
president of the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute,
but he did his
post-doctoral work at MIT with
Mary Lou Pardue.
I'd been a post-doc at Berkeley
when he was just finishing his
graduate work,
and I met him out there.
And then he came to MIT to
do his post-doc.
And a year later I got a job so
I'd become friends
there and became friends when
we started here.
So I had a pretty
close link to this particular
story.
Here's a picture of Tom
together
with Phil.
That's actually my wife right
there who was in this picture.
But Tom actually looks much
more like that.
He's very colorful,
very fun, a very interesting
person.
But anyway,
when Tom left MIT to take a
faculty position at Bolder he
was interested
in trying to understand the
biochemistry of RNA splicing.
And so he went -- He did what a
good scientist will
do.
They'll try and find an
experimental system where the
question they want to address
is simple enough you can
actually get
an answer.
There's a kind of way of doing
science where you pick a
system that's too complicated
and you never actually get an
answer.
It sounds very important
because you're working on
something that's
important but you cannot,
you don't have the tools you
need to get to
the answer.
So Tom wanted to work on the
biochemistry of RNA splicing
because that had just been
discovered.
And so he went to a small
little tiny organism called
tetrahymena.
And the reason he looked at
that was because it had a
ribosomal RNA,
so
it was an RNA that was made in
great abundance within the
organism.
And
it only had one of these
non-coding regions.
I'll tell you the words
for these coding and
non-coding.
To me they're non-intuitive,
but I
guess you should know them.
The coding region is called,
the
part that codes is called an
exon and the non-coding part is
called an
intron.
So, anyway, Tom worked on this
organism because the pre-mRNA
was basically this.
Or the pre-mRNA before the
splicing
looked like this.
This was going to give this
like that.
He could get
large quantities of this RNA,
so he was all set to make
extracts of the
cells of this organism and then
start cooking up this RNA
substrate
with all sorts of cell
extracts.
And then his plan was to purify
the
enzymes that did the RNA
splicing.
And so I first heard about
this, Tom
was working on this when he was
here.
And he went off to,
I guess
it was Denmark to learn how to
grow this organism.
Then they were back
and he was off at Bolder.
And we used to play squash all
the time.
And whenever I got out to
Bolder we'd try and get in a
squash game.
So I was out there at a meeting
and we were sitting around in
the locker
room.
And I said so how's the
splicing biochemistry project
going?
Tom says, well,
it's going OK,
I guess.
There's only one
little problem,
he says.
The controls are splicing.
Now, what he
meant was if you were trying to
add cell extract and get this
thing to
go what you would start out
with is the RNA in a tube
basically.
And that would be your control.
And then you'd start adding
stuff to it
and start looking for splicing.
And what Tom was finding was
that if you
just took this RNA and let it
sit in a test tube that the
splicing
happened without him putting
anything in.
And here he was
already to find all the
enzymes, the proteins that did
it.
And Tom did
an absolutely gorgeous piece of
science to prove that what was
happening was the RNA was
catalyzing its own splicing.
And he had to work very,
very hard to prove that it
wasn't a
contaminating protein.
Remember we had this sort of
discussion?
We
were talking about is DNA the
genetic material and how would
we
know that it wasn't just a
little tiny bit of something
else in our
DNA perhaps that was doing it.
Tom had to go through pretty
much a
similar exercise,
but this was one of these key
insights that lead to
the proof that RNA could
function as a catalyst,
what we now
know as a ribozyme.
And I've shown you now we now
sort
of accept that the actual
ribosome itself is a ribozyme
and that the
formation of the peptide bond,
the thing that's the heart of
all
proteins is made by a ribozyme,
not catalyzed by ribosomes and
not by a
protein.
OK.
So the next topic that I want
to try on which sort of
we've already set up from this
is that if the information is
all in
DNA to begin with then if you
make an RNA copy you're only
taking a
segment of that information at
a time.
And that gives the cells a lot
of possibilities for regulating
how
they respond to the environment
or just controlling what genes
are
expressed.
And there are basically two
kinds of strategies that are
involved in these regulatory
decisions.
They can either be --
Can either be reversible
changes.
For example,
a bacterium and a food source.
If you're a bacterium and
you've got enzymes that let you
eat a hundred different kinds of
food
and you're in an environment
where there's only one of them
there,
you're really wasting energy if
you make the proteins to make
the other
99.
So you might guess that somehow
evolution has selected for
systems
that have learned how to turn
on and off the things they need
to eat
certain food sources depending
on whether the food source
is available.
We only carry umbrellas when it
rains.
If you had to carry an umbrella
and a snowsuit and a
surfboard, everything all the
time, it would slow you down in
evolution.
So the other type,
which we've talked about as
well when we talked
about starting as a single cell
and going to the 10^14 cells
that make
us up, then many of those
changes, as those cells go along
and
progressively more specialized
need to be irreversible.
And this is particularly
important
in development.
We don't want a cell in our
retina suddenly deciding
it should be part of a heart
and start to make a heart in the
middle
of your eye or something like
that.
So things in development tend
to be
once you're off you're off or
once you're on you're on or
something.
And just to give you another
little look at that picture I've
shown you
before of the nematode.
And at the time,
the first time I
showed you this,
I was just trying to emphasize
that we could take the
gene encoding green fluorescent
protein and put it in anything
and
it would go green.
In this case,
Barbara Meyer who is at
Berkeley now
but used to be my office-mate
at MIT for many years,
what she's done is
she's taken that green
fluorescent protein,
the gene for that,
and
she's put it under the control
of a regulatory system,
a gene that is
made to be expressed in the
esophagus of the worm.
And so even though that gene is
present in all the cells of that
organism, it's under the
control of a system that usually
permits the
genes to be made that are
needed for making esophagus but
not in other
parts of the body.
So you probably didn't pick
that part up now but
sort of take another look at
that same thing and see
something
different.
So how do we learn about gene
regulation?
The key work,
like so many of these things,
started kind of
inauspiciously,
if you will.
There were two French
scientists, Jacques
Monod, who is a biochemist,
Francois Jacob who was a
geneticist.
And
they were working on the
metabolism of lactose by E.
coli.
Lactose is galactose,
beta 1,4 glucose.
And you don't have to know
exactly the structure.
You can just remember there
were a lot of
different hydroxyls,
and that was one particular
linkage.
And there's
an enzyme that cleaves this
into galactose and glucose.
And this can
go right into glycolysis and
make energy for the organism.
And the galactose undergoes a
couple of different
transformations,
and it
can get in there as well.
But in order to get at the
energy that's in
those carbohydrates,
this linkage has to be broken.
And it was broken
by an enzyme called
beta-galactosidase.
That's a
protein that's able to catalyze
the cleavage of those two
sugars.
That's what Jacques Monod and
Francois Jacob were studying.
They
were helped out in this
exercise.
I guess part of the reason they
got
going on this was people had
noticed for many years that if
you grew E.
coli in glucose there was no
beta-gal.
I'm going to abbreviate this as
beta-gal just so I won't have to
keep writing the same thing.
But if they grew E.
coli in lactose
beta-gal was present.
And they had to be able to
assay for this enzyme.
And they used --
There were standard types of
biochemical assays you could
use.
But some chemists that helped
design a very cleaver kind of
substrate
that helped them,
that could be used in these
kinds of studies,
and I'll
show you one of them.
What this enzyme really looks
at is it looks
at, let's see,
galactose.
What it sees is sort of the
galactose side of this linkage,
and then it reaches in and
catalyzes the
cleavage of what's joined to
it.
And it turns out not to be
specific
for whether glucose is on the
other side.
It can accept substrates that
have other things as well.
So some chemists made some
variants like
this.
This is a compound that's
commonly known as X-gal.
If you
talk about it in the lab it's
got a longer chemical name.
But what happens if
beta-galactosidase is there,
it's
able to cleave this substrate
so you get galactose,
which is colorless.
But if you get just X,
this is colored,
but up here this original
material is also colorless.
So this is very convenient
because if you
use a substrate such as this
you could put the cells on a
plate with
this indicator.
And if they are colored,
and the
color is blue,
you'd know they were making
beta-galactosidase.
And if
you don't see a color,
you know they're not.
There are a variety of
ways of assaying for this
enzyme.
With that I'm just trying to
give
you a little bit of flavor of
one of the different ways that
they could
assay for it.
Now, one of the issues was it
looked as though E.
coli didn't have any
beta-galactosidase activity if
lactose was absent when growing
in glucose.
And they made it if lactose was
present.
Well, that would be kind
of what you would expect
evolution would have figured out
how to do,
only make the enzyme for
metabolizing lactose if the
lactose
is present, but they had to
figure out what the molecular
basis of this
was.
And one of the possibilities
was that the protein was made
that
it was all sort of unfolded,
and when the substrate came in
then it
folded all around it and then
it could cleave it.
Or another possibility,
which would be the kind we're
talking about now,
is the protein is not made
until the lactose is present,
and then it
makes it new.
So they had to figure out,
between these two,
which of
these two was true.
When you see the lactose
present, is it just
beta-galactosidase is already
made but it's inactive,
or is it being
made de novo when you add the
lactose?
So what they did was they grew
cells in glucose plus
radioactive
C14-leucine for a long time.
So all the proteins --
-- were radioactive.
And once they
got, that's going for a long
time.
So every protein being
made is radioactive.
Then they add excess unlabeled
leucine.
So this means that from now on
any new proteins that are
made will not be radioactive
because you're just going to
swamp out any
radioactive stuff with this.
And they added glucose,
excuse me, now
they added lactose to the cells.
And then they isolated the
beta-gal enzyme.
It was actually pretty easy
to do.
It's a huge enzyme and it's a
tetramer.
So very large.
Even in
those days it was fairly easy
to isolate this enzyme.
And then they
looked to see is it
radioactive?
If it's radioactive it was
there all
along and it's refolded to
become the active enzyme.
Or if it had been only after
lactose then it would be made de
novo in
response to it.
And what they found was that it
was non-radioactive.
Which implied that it was made
after
you added the lactose.
So they knew then that they
were
studying a system in which a
protein was only made after the
cells had
experienced a particular growth
substrate.
And so a lot of work
went into figuring out how this
system worked.
Let's see.
We're a
little short on time.
So I'll tell you what I'll do.
I'll
tell you, I'll just put out
quickly the mechanics of what
they saw, and
we'll start in on the
regulation on how this works.
And some of you may
be able to figure it out.
What we now know is that the
gene that
encodes beta-galactosidase is
in a stretch of DNA that's
pretty
interesting.
It's got three genes.
It's the gene lacZ.
This is the
gene for beta-galactosidase.
And another gene called lacY
and
lacA.
There's a promoter.
That's a start signal for
transcription.
Remember that?
So there's a sequence here that
says start
transcription.
Down here is a terminator.
Another word written in the
nucleic acid alphabet that means
stop making
mRNA.
And there is one long mRNA,
as you can see,
that has the
peculiarity of encoding three
different genes.
So if you have
more than one gene in a single
message then that's
called an operon.
You've got one mRNA.
But, in any case,
so whenever beta-galactosidase
was being made then RNA has to
start being made here,
goes to there.
And
we won't worry about the
functions of these other two
genes.
But, as you might guess from
the way evolution has selected
for it, they
have related activities to what
beta-galactosidase does.
And for
bacteria it's a very efficient
way to control the expression of
a bunch
of genes at once.
Then there was another gene up
here known as lacI
that had a promoter and a
terminator, and it made
an mRNA as well.
And that mRNA encoded a protein
that's known as the lac
repressor.
And what that lac repressor
does,
it's a protein that has the
ability to recognize a very,
very specific
DNA sequence and bind there.
And I'm just going to kind of
blow up
this part of the thing.
So what we have here is the,
this is
the promoter here.
And it happens that the binding
sequence --
-- for lac repressor overlaps
with
the promoter.
Weird, right?
Maybe not.
So I'll tell you,
well, you can think about this
over the weekend,
if you haven't run into this
system before.
So this gene gets made all
the time.
So this protein gets made all
What does that
protein do if it's just like
this?
Its job in life is to look for
this
sequence and bind to it.
If it binds to it,
it covers
up the promoter.
And the beta-galactosidase gene
is
not expressed because the cell
cannot make mRNA.
So this may seem
a little obscure,
but there's something very
important here.
Now
the conditionality on whether
this gene is expressed or not is
controlled by a protein,
right?
It's controlled by this lac
repressor.
If it's on there the gene won't
be made.
And if it's
off the gene now you can make
it.
There's a promoter and the RNA
polymerase will see it.
And so you've learned something
about
proteins.
They can bind various things.
And so what lac repressor
has, it's got a little binding
site that lactose is able to
bind to and
change the confirmation of the
lac repressor.
So why don't you take
those pieces of information and
see if you can figure out how
the circuitry goes.
Yeah?
Did I do something wrong?
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
Excuse me.
Yes, Z-Y-A.
OK?
We'll walk
through that on Monday,
but focus on the fact that if
the repressor is
there and lactose isn't,
it binds to this sequence.
The repressor is made all the
time, but this repressor is
something that
can tell you whether lactose is
there or not.
So you can put the circuit
together, OK?